because we've lost so much recently we
face extraordinary challenges but it is
a new day in america it's inauguration
day for joe biden and here's what it
looks like this morning
the west front of the capitol where by
noon today
joe biden will be sworn in as the 46th
president
of the united states of america our
chief white house correspondent that's
nancy cordes is there nancy
good morning to you i can't imagine what
it feels like there
good morning and welcome to a slightly
windy washington d.c
gale this is a view that never gets old
that balcony behind me is where
president-elect biden
will deliver his inaugural address in a
few short hours
but first this morning he'll attend mass
at
the cathedral of saint matthew the
apostle just down the road republican
leaders mitch mcconnell
and kevin mccarthy will join him at the
service as will
democratic leaders mr biden then heads
here to the capitol where he'll be sworn
in by chief justice john roberts vice
president-elect kamala harris will be
sworn in
by justice sonia sotomayor the bidens
are then going to head to arlington
national cemetery
to lay a wreath at the tomb of the
unknown soldier and finally
mr biden will then be escorted to the
white house followed by
a virtual inaugural parade last night
the president-elect arrived here in
washington d.c
setting the tone with a somber ceremony
honoring
the victims of the pandemic
[Music]
president-elect joe biden's first stop
in washington was the lincoln memorial
to heal we must remember
to honor the more than 400 thousand in
america
who have lost their lives to coronavirus
between
sundown and dusk let us shine the lights
in the darkness along the sacred pool of
reflection
remember all whom we lost four hundred
eight-foot tall lights now surround the
reflecting pool on the national mall
the biden team says today marks a new
approach to managing the pandemic
once he is sworn in mr biden is expected
to sign
15 executive orders and take two
additional
executive actions including a nationwide
mass mandate on federal property
and the creation of a white house office
to respond to the virus
to give this committee the truth a third
of his cabinet nominees sat for
confirmation hearings tuesday
laying out a massive shift in policy and
tone from the past four years i look
forward to leading the intelligence
community
democrats say their top priority is
getting mr biden's homeland security
nominee mr mayorka so welcome back
alejandro mayorkas confirmed so help you
god
i do especially after the recent attack
on the capitol
but missouri senator josh hawley
announced he would block a swift
confirmation
because he opposes the new
administration's immigration plans
if people qualify under the law to
remain in the united states
then we will apply the law accordingly
mr biden's political career spans
five decades he first ran for the
presidency more than
30 years ago it's a career that began in
delaware
his father moved the family there after
he lost his job
before coming to washington tuesday mr
biden bid a teary farewell
to his home state excuse the emotion
but
when i die delaware written on my heart
the president-elect spoke at the
national guard base
named for his late son beau an iraq war
veteran who mr biden
often thought had a future in the white
house
i only have one regret he's not here
because he should be introducing him as
president
among the executive orders
president-elect biden is expected to
sign today
are a cancellation of president trump's
ban on travelers from some muslim
countries
an extension of limits on evictions and
student loan payments
and rejoining the paris climate
agreement so
a very busy first day tony nancy
quarters for us from what's been called
democracy's front porch nancy thank you
very much